i first met our next speaker and his
lovely lovely wife penny
when i went out to claremont many years
ago to graduate school
he was the president at the time of the
claremont institute
and uh what i quickly learned about him
is that
you know he's a teacher it's something
that hillsdale students learn about him
today
he's a teacher he's always teaching he
didn't teach formal classes back then as
he does now
but we graduate students certainly
learned a lot from him
and he always took the time to talk to
us when we had
questions back in those days when we
were younger
and sillier we used to kid him that he
was a college professor trapped in a
think tank president's body
now i guess he's a college professor in
a college president's body
well if you come to see us on the
hillsdale campus and we hope you do
you'll see that he hasn't changed a bit
he's still teaching and he's now
offering formal classes on a variety of
subjects
those subjects include aristotle the
constitution
and c.s lewis and just last fall he
taught a course on
totalitarian novels some of you may have
seen his essay in the december
2020 issue of in primus where he
discussed one of those novels george
orwell's
1984. well he's still pushing his
students to defend their opinions
as he did with us and think them through
more more clearly and deeply
because the goal of an education uh
worthy of the name is discovering the
truth about things
and that's not easy it's been my
privilege and honor to work with him
at hillsdale my alma mater for now more
than 20 years
please welcome him back to the podium
the 12th president of hillsdale college
larry p yarn
thank you tim how are you
so i want to begin with two personal
things uh
one is show the picture
now we're not behind in our capital
campaign but if we were i would auction
that baby off right now
[Laughter]
except my wife sits back there and she
told me i mustn't that's charlotte
theresa
and everybody thinks she's just like her
grandfather
thank you okay that's enough of her
nobody wants to look at me
um i want to tell you some stories about
rush limbaugh
because i've led a weird life
for different reasons i've known mark
levin and hugh hewitt since a long time
before they got into radio
and i've met rush limbaugh for the first
time in 1984 the year his cr his career
was just taking off
he was in sacramento california and i
had business up there i'd go
and the cab drivers were all listening
to him and talking about how great he
was
and then i ran across him in a hotel and
i looked walked up and shook his hand
and i said
you're dynamite he said well yes i am
i i know him often well i've you know
i've known him that's 36 years ago
uh he uh
would come and speak for things that i
was hosting at the claremont student
here and i found out about him so
i know him personally pretty well he's
shy
can you believe that he's very shy and
he once came to washington dc to speak
at a dinner
where newt gingrich was speaking and he
asked us to
drape off a little area behind the stage
where he could drink diet coke
and wait to give his speech and he
he sat back there and there were like
600 people there
and i walked back there and i said rush
there's 600 people out there who would
just love to see you
why don't you come have some dinner he
said no i'm drinking my diet coke
and he gave his speech and he walked
back in that room and he went to his
airplane and he went home
and i i said next time i saw him i said
you're a really weird guy
and he said i am am i not uh
he got to talking about the college and
this was you know when this was
12 years ago and he something about him
about it you know he likes the college
and he knew a lot about it but he
struck his fancy and we got this huge
response
every time he mentions on the radio the
phones would
get jammed up and then he
he called one day and he said i want you
to advertise on my show
and you know he had a big wait list of
people to advertise on his show so and i
happen to know that so i knew it was
kind of an honor but i thought it was an
odd idea
let's advertise at college on the rush
limbaugh show
and i said okay i'll think about it and
then he sent craig
kitchen who's his number one producer
will be grieving today
out to hillsdale twice and both times
he sat all afternoon through an
aristotle class
he said i was teaching it he said i want
to get a sense of what this college is
about and i said okay well
come with me and he just you know he he
i thought that was a remarkable
demonstration of patience on the man
and you know i didn't do anything about
it and then uh
in this first week that obama was
elected president
he said to a bunch of people you've got
to stop listening to rush limbaugh
and so i came to the monday morning
staff meeting and i said
uh we're going to examine this week
whether to advertise on rush limbaugh
and john cevini back there said so the
president made you mad didn't he and i
said yeah
because you know that's the specific
thing that the president united states
is supposed to protect
us listening to and saying what we want
to right
it's our rights and he's an agent of
those rights
except not and that did tick me off
and that's why we decided to do that and
then of course it went wild
uh over the years i would uh
go see him once a year down in palm
beach
he lived right on the coast in palm
beach but the
as you if you've ever been there you
know it's a very precious place
and now they wouldn't let him do his pro
radio program out of his house
violated the zoning so about
five blocks away sort of in the more
more office area he bought a
three-story building four-story building
and kept it empty
he was the only one in it and uh
you go see him and uh you'd arrive
always on friday
as he was finishing his show 3 30 i
think
and uh you go up and then you go through
you know
there weren't very many people there
there were like three people helping him
do the show and craig kitchen was always
there
and we would sit and talk for an hour
and it was just a hoot
and he would always make fun of me the
next
monday so
one day he said the best conversation he
said
what do you want me to say about the
college and i said i want you to say
it's hard
and he said hard and he looked at craig
kitchen he said you know we've been in
radio for 40 years
anybody ever asked us to say that before
i said yeah say it's hard and he said
how hard is it and i said what's hard
he said how many people get above a four
point
and i said we don't do that and he said
how many get a four point i said that
time it was seven
he said seven that's not many i said
rush seven in 15 years
[Laughter]
you know we've got great inflation now
that's up to like 20.
and uh we had two in one year the other
day and we all felt a couple of years
ago we all felt ashamed of ourselves
and he said well why don't they get it
a four point is it chemistry and i said
yeah chemistry's hard
everybody has to take that physics
biology math
everybody has to take all that and i
said probably the hardest department to
get an a in is the
english department and if not that
politics
he said english and politics are hard
i said well russia if you want to
understand them
you know we don't we don't give out many
a's
the average kid coming to hillsdale
college has a 3.92 from high school
and the average freshman gets a 2.87
we call that chart going across the
years shock and
awe
and you know we recruit by frightening
them to death we show them that chart
and the recruiting you know because
they're all
used to making a's and they've got to
they've got to lose that
they've got to not
identify their self-esteem with making
a's
and you know we always have a bunch that
make 3.94
you know there's a lot of them but uh we
don't like them getting all a's all the
way through so the next
uh and he said tell me how you make the
constitution course
hard and i said rush the constitution
united states is according to james
madison
a picture of the human soul also
a picture of the order of nature and
he starts out when he talks about it
early in the federalist papers it's like
a
a mechanism cancel this out right so
nobody gets to dominate and
pursue their own interest but it changes
as it goes and it becomes
simply beautiful and i i
quoted those passages to him in the 49s
and 51st federalists
so then the next monday
you know he's supposed to talk about us
for
i don't know how long i'm in it or
something and he very often went
five minutes six minutes very long time
in radio
this next monday he went 20 minutes
and he just told all about that
conversation and he said at the end
he said for the first time in my life i
wish i had gone to college
and i'm going to go visit hillsdale
college
which she never did but on the other
hand
we were forever i mean how many times
has our call center asked the question
answer the question
when is rush limbaugh coming so
he was a he was a very bright man
he uh whatever he said to me once he
said
how do you manage a college and i have
some opinions about how you manage
things
mostly from churchill the safeguard and
the glory of mankind
is that it is easy to lead and hard to
drive
so you don't want to hire anybody to do
anything they don't want to do
and you don't hire anybody who doesn't
understand the goals
you don't don't hire anybody who isn't
honest and then after that
let them do their work and help them
when you need to
once in a while tell them no but not
often so i told them that
and uh then he said to me he said okay
he said uh le at the end of that
conversation i was about to leave he
said
would you suggest some things that i
should say
and i said russia you haven't been
listening to me
and he said how not and i said
are you the best at this and he said
yeah i said haven't i just told you what
i hope you can help people
understand he said yeah i said
probably you should figure out how to do
that huh
he's a very interesting guy very
he worked you know he was rich as crisis
i don't know what he's doing with the
money i hope he gives it to us but
uh
but he has you know he has a family and
he grew up 50 miles from where i grew up
we played on the same
baseball field in literally a couple
times not at the same time
uh and uh
he he didn't have to work he just
loved to work and he worked uh
probably 12 hours a day
three doing the show nine getting ready
and he studied and he
he would text me and ask me questions
about things going on
anyway he was a great man and
you know in this day and age of course
he's been being painted in the darkest
colors
in the press another thing is
russia is hilarious he could be really
serious but then
mostly it was just hilarious did you
ever hear
i didn't listen to his show very much i
talked to him more and i listened to his
show but
i listen sometimes once it was a became
a famous one
he was talking about his life in his
apartment complex in
new york before he moved to palm beach
he said he'd uh he'd go there and he'd
uh
get settled down for a long evening's
work and he'd order takeout from like
five places
he lost a lot of weight before he died i
mean
years before he died but he was kind of
tubby
and he said that it became very
inconvenient
because the takeout guys were forbidden
to come upstairs
because they would go all over the
apartment complex or the condo complex
and put
menus under everybody's door and people
thought that was tanky
truck rush didn't mind so
it's causing him you know because he
says you know i'm in my boxer shorts
and i got to put on my trousers and go
down and get my food that's just
terrible until one day i figured it out
he called the the uh what he called the
porter
he said would you please admit my dinner
jess
my dinner guest role
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i liked russia
yeah you know i i can't even remember
what it is now and of course that
will be that's because i'm a racist but
or something
but he did something that brought a
storm down on him
and uh i can't remember what it was but
uh you know of course media matters is
an outfit that
hassles conservatives in the media
and they managed to break into our
server
and get the email addresses of the
students and the faculty and the staff
and send everybody an email about how
shameful
it was that hillsdale college would
advertise on rush limbaugh
and you know we that's a little
inconvenient
and it didn't cause much trouble oddly
enough
but then i got a call from a journalist
from the huffington post
and i took it and i said what do you
want she said
are you going to cancel your
advertisements on rush limbaugh and i
said no
not going to do that and she said why
not i said because you're the one asking
[Laughter]
[Applause]
one of the most serious things he ever
said he learned of that
and uh one of them you know he lost a
couple of advertisers
over that window blinds or something and
uh he looked at me and he said
you know that was very noble and i said
what and he said
you didn't run away and i said you know
rush if i was we were the kind of people
to do that
would we have been here in the first
place you know
it's a crazy thing to do but it was a
good thing to do um
because it how it works right we
we think we have some beautiful things
to teach
we think they're world-saving we think
they're soul-saving
whether they serve the world or not and
we want to teach as many people as we
can
that's in the original articles all who
wish
without regard to race sex or national
origin
and that's what the college was in the
civil war days when it was a very
influential thing and it's an
influential thing again and so we want
to talk to a lot of people
and you know we don't advertise on the
huffington post because
cnn is not a good field for us and
because why because it's not so much
just that people are conservative that
helps it's that they're conservative
people who are interesting to know
interested to know serious things and so
because of rush limbaugh but because of
all of the other things we do
i'm proud to have before me the best
audience in america
thank you
[Applause]
okay i'm uh back on my kathy grammer
task now
raheem helped with that didn't he you
feel better kathy
yeah yeah well i have to say some bad
stuff and then you'll feel better after
that
um kathy likes
for me us to manage her mood
by the way i don't think your
grandchildren are as handsome as mine
what do you think
wrong wrong yeah we're not going to
reach agreement on that
um so here's the bad stuff
uh what has happened is revolutionary
and why it has happened is revolutionary
and exceedingly dangerous
uh the wad is the electoral system
of the country is at least in part
compromised
and the electoral system is the fulcrum
of everything
it's it's a simple relationship
we are the sovereign and we are outside
the government
and the government has all the power to
act we don't do anything ourselves we're
not the legislature we're not the
executive we don't judge
we elect people who do it and that means
and
when that those arrangements were set up
they were sublimely
effective and madison describes in
another beautiful place in the
federalist papers
the effect of that because every human
use of power
should never be absolute or unchecked
and that includes
even by us the sovereign so we can do
anything we want to do
but it's going to take some time and
that means that we have to think before
we act
in that mood james madison is like your
mom think before you act
you know all the rules by the way that
are are worth making
they're all stuff your mom and dad would
have told you when you're a kid
and any other rules can never be
remembered
but so that's the thing right
the first step in the constitution is
it delays our direct control of the
government
and it's not that way in athens where
the people got an amphitheater and
voted and then next week got an
amphitheater and boarded something else
and it's not like the monarchies where
the
king or queen is the executive branch
we're just the sovereign and
the government works for us but it does
all the work
now when those relationships were set up
they were amazingly stable for a long
time until the civil war
and then they were restored by the very
great abraham lincoln
but that part of the reason for that was
the government was about ten percent of
the economic activity in the country
eight or ten and most of that was
federal and local
the federal government was one or two
percent
well now it's put it all together and
it's pretty much a top-down system now
kind of unified
although not fully unified which is an
important strategic fact for the future
um it's now over 50
so you wonder why are all these fortune
500 companies so politically correct
partly the cause is their bosses all
went to the best colleges by which i
mean the worst
and part of it is explained by the fact
that
the force that can stand up to them if
there is any in the world
is the government and the government is
staffed now by a major bureaucracy
the actual work of the american
government is done by in the
at the federal level about two and a
half million civilian employees
at the state level 20 some million
but they all follow rules that are made
inside the agencies not laws anymore
made in the congress
so the point is there's this system and
it's
because it's so big it's a mighty weight
in the election process and that's been
a creeping problem
you know big problem and creeping bigger
for decades now
and i've been railing against it well
now h.r one
first bill nancy pelosi has put
in is going to put dc in the senate
and it's going to impose a national
system of vote harvesting
and that means this stuff that happens
right where you don't know where the
ballots come from
of bells lots of ballots it's just
something wrong with not knowing where
they come from
and and uh you know i i don't know if
donald trump won or not
i don't myself know but i know that
how michigan was stolen because i have
the misfortune sometimes to live there
and that gets me to the cause first of
all
you know and look at the thing what are
the things to mess with the electoral
system ballot harvesting dc
statehood a new interpretation of voting
rights
what voting rights you know that's the
15th amendment what was passed was
everybody gets to vote
well that's much embellished now so that
districts are
arranged to figure out who wins
on race and other identity group lines
now
and so you could get a kind of a uh a
nationally politically correct
constituency
you know what 19 or 20 million illegals
about to be legal probably by executive
order
which is an interesting phenomenon
because uh
one of the causes of the of the
revolutionary war
in the causes against the king in the
declaration of independence is
that he had expanded the territory of
quebec
southwards and he did that because he
gave quebec
a new constitution and they didn't kick
about it
and it was the constitution he liked
where he could control it and then he
moved some
american colonists into that canadian
colony in other words
now it's not the people truly choosing
the rulers
it's the rulers choosing the people
so that too that illegal immigration
stuff that just reverses the
relationship perfectly
and i think that's its object um
and then anybody tries to strike that
down
the supreme court is living now under a
threat of being packed
and that's exactly like the threat that
franklin roosevelt made in 1936
and he probably would have done it
except the court
changed his mind about all his programs
and started authorizing them
so that means a massive political force
which amounts to a rearrangement of the
constitutional authority and the
direction that power flows
out rather than in
that is far advanced and maybe complete
i don't know
i'll tell you what happened in michigan
we know them and my general counsel has
spent uh
his hair is gray he's been spending time
with him and he gives him advice for
nothing
he doesn't act for them uh he's also
given advice he just told me yesterday
the
the recalcitrant spingles restaurant in
jonesville
michigan six miles from the campus
has refused to close and
bob has been helping him out and i told
bob i said that's controversial
please do it but try to stay out of the
paper
and then the next night mr spingler
was on fox news wearing a hillsdale
college sweatshirt
and thanking bob norton for the help
now here's an interesting thing about
presidential elections
uh to understand the constitutional
system
it's it is as much it is both it's two
things
it is a system of concentrating power
more than was possible under the
articles of confederation
but also it's a elaborate system of
distributing power
out across the land so first of all
the federal government has a list of 17
things in article 1 section 8 that it's
supposed to be able to do
states are not constrained that way
they can do whatever is in the police
power which is an old common law of
power to act for the general welfare
so the federal government is meant to be
about certain things
and supreme only on those an interesting
fact by the way is that
education is not listed in those 17
things
so the way
elections run are
radically decentralized so
the state's control and just they
controlled their own elections
except now there are court cases and
stuff that got the federal government
intervening all the time
they control their own but then for the
federal elections
each house the senate in the house gets
his name to be the judge of the con
conventions credentials of its own
members and that means if a state sends
a rep and they think he's fraudulently
elected they can
eject him and ask for another one they
can't name the other one they can ask
for another one
that rarely happens but it does happen
presidential elections now that means by
the way that
laws were passed they're old in michigan
and they're
similar to the way election laws work in
america and they're mostly pretty good
but they were passed by the legislature
and signed by the governor
and that means that only another law
passed by the legislature and signed by
the governor could
overturn it except this summer
the attorney general and the secretary
of state and the governor
began to negotiate changes in the
election laws
this is the basic michigan election loss
and they can't do that by themselves but
they did and the legislature
a republican majority which increased in
the last election in both houses
did nothing uh
urged them to didn't
the presidential election is a special
case
because the and there's a big debate
about this in the constitutional
convention
and of all of the provisions in the
constitution this is one of the more
clear
because what they wanted was they wanted
to
generalize the process of selecting the
president
and distribute it all over the country
so the first idea was national popular
vote
james madison and governor clinton of
new york strange bedfellows they didn't
get along very much mostly
that didn't go anywhere
so then they said the governors in the
states should pick
but the trouble is there aren't very
many governors and so
one could make deals to get something in
exchange for his vote
so they argued that through and then the
next stage was
state legislatures they're numerous
enough of them that it's hard to make
individual deals
and then they added a refinement on top
of that and the refinement is exactly
parallel to the ratification process
where
the constitution was ratified by
conventions by people
elected on a ticket yes or no to the
constitution
and they serve that one function and
then they disappeared forever
which is one of the reasons the
constitution is not constantly being
amended
well this they said no the legislators
shall be in control of the manner of
choosing electors state
legislatures that means not the governor
and not the courts
state legislatures have control of that
and the only time the federal government
can intervene
in that is if the states send
conflicting slates of legislators
and that did not happen this time from
any of the five republican
controlled battleground states where
they accepted the results
however in most of those states michigan
for sure also pennsylvania
also wisconsin probably the others
or two more they had watched their
procedures being changed
and not done anything about it what
we thought they should do in the summer
was
announced that they have soul control
over the selection of the electors
and you're changing it we reserve the
right to pick our own slate
now that would have been a firestorm all
the national press
somebody who runs google would have said
something bad about them
and now the nbc news would be displeased
right
in other words their life would be very
intense
because they actually have the power to
do that
and to do it when to do it was august
before the ballot started coming in and
they didn't
and i think i know i know
them many of them i think i know why
they didn't
uh
it's something you learn if you go to
the right college
what you are depends on how you live
your life
and they needed to do two things that
they didn't do
because and it's not just they neglected
two things
these things would only come if they
live their lives in a certain way
first of all they would need to know
deeply
their responsibilities and authorities
they take an oath to pursue them you
know
on the 1776 commission i took an oath to
the constitution
first time i've ever done it and you
know
i'm obliged to that now it doesn't end
because i got fired
you know in the past i was that
this alone is denied even to god to make
what has been not to have been
so uh and you know all this cancel stuff
by the way
it is just the most obvious truth in the
world that that cannot be done
and that means you know i i fear it
because if they start doing it to me in
their various ways they could
then you know i would have a world of
turmoil
but i wouldn't have the fear that that
could be ultimately successful
because it happened or it didn't
they didn't live their lives in a way to
understand deeply things like the fact
that they
are in sole control of the manner of
choosing the electors
what a tremendous responsibility what a
tremendous power
and they were unaware of it one member
of the leadership
didn't know that the legislature had the
subpoena power
another one uh opined that uh
the governor was the leader of the
legislature
and uh see isn't that funny everybody
knows everybody here knows better than
that right
and his argument was well she has the
veto power which basically
gives her one third of the votes she's
the senior legislator
and so there then ensued a sophomore
high school
lesson in separation of powers and
you see that that person ran for office
got elected is a good person with
broadly correct political opinions
according to my lights
he didn't know basic stuff
right it's like a carpenter don't know
how to
build with wood and you know the very
best carpenters
they live their lives in a way so they
get really good at that and it takes a
commitment
more than the normal you see
and they haven't made that and then the
second thing is
to do bold and courageous things you
have to practice
you have to practice in your mind you
know
that that's uh another word for that is
worry
you uh you know you think i don't have
everybody who everybody who works for me
every all the vice presidents here all
the ones who are not here
we basically live our jobs it's kind of
weird
and we like each other and we love our
jobs and we know how to relax
but uh we practice all the time
what if they do this what will we do
what if we do that
what we do every big step we take is
calculated
uh in in light of its effects upon the
dangers that might come
across upon the college and that's why
the college is the one
independent one we care about it
we give ourselves to it we study it all
the time
and then we think how will we comport
ourselves
when terrible things happen to us as
they will
right and you have to get your mind
around that
and you have to get your mind around
that in advance
if you want to see how that works uh in
book two of aristotle's ethics
there's the riveting discussion of
courage
and in there he explains what makes a
courageous act and he says that if you
want to see him look at the battlefield
because there's a lot of them happen
there
because everybody has good reason to be
afraid
and the point is if you do that if you
think about that
what would i do right then
when it comes it's not new to you
what would i do if the
governor and the secretary of the state
and the attorney general
set out to alter the electoral laws
including the ones for the presidency
without consulting us what if
doing that which they did
they also refused to answer any
questions from us
what if the governor in michigan we have
two
uh emergency laws and uh
i'm coming to think now that we passed
bad laws right after great wars
one of them was passed in 1946 and it
basically lets the governor declare an
emergency and sustain it for a long time
long doesn't say when it ends and then
in the 70s they passed a
more sane emergency law the more recent
law then
and in the 70s it says that she she can
declare an emergency
within 30 days she's got to go to the
legislature and get them to agree
and then they can extend for 30 days but
every 30 days she's got to talk to him
that's the way they work in all the good
states and that's most of the states
right but no
she started out by the way when the
pandemic hit
under the 1975 law the one where she had
to consult
and then she got her extension and then
they refused an extension
so she immediately went to the 1945 law
which proves by the way that she knew
about the 1975 law
and they just she just ran over them
for months and they you know and they
sue her in the courts right what if
instead they just
didn't vote any money she can't spend
money without him appropriating it
they did the other day in an act of
great boldness
uh say that they're not going to
act on any of her appointments to
commissions
if she doesn't straighten up you know
and
you know i happen to know as of two
weeks ago
from election day until two weeks ago
the governor and the attorney general
and the secretary of state
had not answered a single question from
the legislature
not in writing and not in verbally right
and they won't come and testify they
just they just
flout them now we
what they should have got if they'd just
done this thing that we're going to
see she couldn't stop that constitution
is a very clever thing if you know how
it works
she they could send a second slate of
electors
to washington because this slate wasn't
chosen according to the law
and there's no power on earth that could
stop them doing that
and all the presidents say that when
that happens then the senate has got to
make it a senate and the house have got
to make a decision
and they didn't do that they didn't
threaten it and if they
threatened it or later done it but
threatening it would be way better
then they'd say but i'll tell you why
if we can devise some procedures to make
sure that these ballots are held in
custody
and protected and that everybody gets to
vote
and everybody gets to vote once and
nobody gets to vote for them
right and those requests would have had
wide public support
they would have been operating during a
firestorm
but the only way you're going to survive
that and get any changes if you use
something that
constitutes a real power and they have a
real power and that's what it's for
and they don't have an absolute power
that would be wrong
and the governor doesn't have an
absolute power that would be wrong and
wrong for her to pretend that she does
so that means that first of all it's
very hard to know
if the ballots were fair we know that
there were millions
stored in warehouses the location of
only the one of the warehouses is known
it was said once by the secretary of
state state there was nine of them
scattered around the state and the one
that's known
neighbors report people went in and out
all the time
what were they doing you know they
weren't
observers there weren't you know as far
as we know
so you see what that means is that's a
raw assertion of power
over the people
you see and i must say
that was not pointed out by her
opposition in the legislature
so and that's what i say is the worst
thing
i say that
we didn't stop this because we weren't
ready to
and we weren't ready to because we don't
live right
but that also turns to the a good thing
and that is isn't it true
that if you get slaughtered it's better
if the fault is in you
because then maybe you can do something
about it
how we doing kathy you feeling better
yeah right in other words
i mean we don't have to be abraham
lincoln
we just have to get better than these
guys to do better
and and so i actually take
heart from that although this is a
power grab of the very first order
and where is it going to go i'll say my
last gloomy thing
did i tell you about this spanish
professor i hired did i talk about that
last night
it's my favorite subject right now
there's a guy named carano and he's
going to teach spanish at hillsdale
college
and you know if you if you apply for a
job at hillsdale college
you won't be applying for a better job
because there isn't one
because it's got all the features right
everybody's smart everybody works
everybody's nice to each other the kids
are naughty in just the right amount
um or sometimes a little more but
this guy was a full professor
in his 40s at venezuela
and a prominent academic figure there
and he had to run for his life he
he he left his property behind he left
his job behind
and he got to america because they were
inflating his salary around
away and he lived under constant threat
about whatever he might say
and so now he's here and he needs a job
because he can't stay if he doesn't get
a really good job
it has to be a permanent job to look
right on the visa
so what it effectively means is he needs
this job
and there are two others who are also
very good and i drew all that out of him
i i get him to tell me i try to find out
what do they love
you can always predict people's behavior
if you know what they love
and so i got into all that and he told
me all about it
and of course my heart went out to him
and i said
you know i don't know if you're going to
get this job or not
and see i have the power to give it to
him by myself but i don't do that
because
my colleagues are so good and they have
more time to think about it and i do
and so i do overrule them once in a
while but not often
and never before i find out what they're
going to do anyway
i said i don't know what's going to
happen but i'll make you a promise
i've been running a one-man immigration
service for 40 years
if i see somebody really worthy i try to
help them become citizens in the united
states
i will do that for you and he cried
in my office right and my point is
that's what it's like when your country
sinks into despotism
it is not a happy thing
so we have to stop that
how my last point
come find out i know a little bit about
winston churchill and uh
he he is just the man for right now
what happened to him in his life he has
spent his life for seeing and trying to
prevent
the great world wars instead it was his
fate to fight them he spent his life
warning about socialism in the mornings
he said
it'll it'll end the freedom of the
british people
it will also end our ability to feed
ourselves
there'll be a collapse we'll have to
depopulate partly the island
those kind of warnings all his life
beginning in 1898
when he was 26 years old and continuing
right through to his death in 65 but
in the 1945 election they just simply
swept
the socialists for the first time they
beat him or his party the war hero
right and he was devastated do you see
he's in exactly our position except
worse
because i've been warning about all this
all my life warning that they're going
to
rig the electoral system so you can't
get them out
oh and now it's happened right probably
and i think about him and see
he had laid the ground he was also how
old was he 45
26. so he was 60
72. he you know he'd won
glory everybody thought he was the
greatest man in the world even his
enemies
and so of course the reliable times of
london
worse now but bad then they called it
it's time for him to retire
he can be the great world statesman
which he did become by the way
but uh now the conservative party needs
new blood
and the socialists are going to get
their chance
and you know he was devastated by that
election took him two or three weeks to
get his daughter up
and then he says i stayed till the pub
closes
and i fight for my corner and then he
launched a whole strategy and it's the
one we have to launch today
he said we've been warning about these
things that they're going to do
for decades now they're going to do them
now they will be visible beyond
mistake and so we are going to oppose
them
we're going to call out what they do
we're going to use that
to persuade the people that we have to
change
now it took seven years
because they'd won a huge majority and
couldn't get them out but he beat him
soon and then he gets to be prime
minister again
and i'll give you one of his arguments
this is the very best
and you know it's hard by the way to get
arguments out these days
because social media and all that but
the truth is
the alternatives are also easy and cheap
and you know they don't they don't have
a monopoly on the internet
uh here's a great thing do you know
about the browser brave
yeah get that yeah and they've done
something that i think is really awesome
uh there's a protocol i'm about to get
to be a tanki here for a minute
there's a protocol called called uh
interplanetary file system
ipfs
and the guy who who uh invented it is
from stanford he's a young guy
and you can find on youtube him giving a
talk about it at sanford
and this file system is incorporated
into the brave browser now now here's
what it does
the way the internet works is
to find any piece of information on it
you you find the domain where it is
and then you find the thing in the
domain and it's the fact that the
that you get to all the files through a
particular domain
that lets facebook own everything on it
for example whereas what this does
is it replicates the file
around the internet in various places
and the file address is just
to the file and he says
because he's not stupid this guy he's
very smart he's a nerdy kind of engineer
guy
but what he says is that will make the
internet
freer and harder to censor
and it doesn't take infrastructure so
uh right now uh you know these huge
server farms
that you know they're you know they they
deal with half a continent
well those belong to about five
companies
if you distribute this way you can just
go through and around them both
now it's an interesting thing to me
because that guy gave a very clever talk
you know because he's dealing with
things that are very sensitive
like google the big the big guerrilla
thrown off parlor and throwing off trump
and throwing off everybody right
and and amazon doing the same and all of
an apple doing the same
those guys are bad and uh
and he is giving a talk about how you
could get around that
and he does it very gently i think he
ought to go into politics
but you but you can tell what he's
saying and then
our commencement speaker is tim allen
this year
i said to him mr allen you're the most
requested
commencement speaker after clarence
thomas and he said
clarence thomas i can kick his ass
[Laughter]
commencement's going to be fun this year
but he says he knows a bunch of people
who are big up in the tech world
and that they are very disturbed by
what's going on in there
and they want to find a way out of it
now that brings me that's churchill's
point right
his point is they're going to do these
things now
and they will be less able to pretend
that they're not what they seem
and people will be
persuaded or else by the way
the american people are ready to be
desperatized
and that means we're the walking dead
already
but i don't think that and i'm just
going to close with this this is one of
the prettiest things about winston
churchill
i had a lifelong friend a violet bottom
carter beautiful woman grandmother of
helena
carter the actress
and they were sweet on each other for a
little while when they were young
and it was before churchill figured out
how to court a woman
so he would take her out and they'd
memorize
noble speeches and poems that's
he got better when clemmy came along
but he he memorized with violet the poem
i'm going to read to you
and that was in 1904
1903 got married in 1908
but now it's april 27 1941
and britain is alone russia and germany
are together
america is aloof overwhelming power
being brought to bear on the island
and you know two months later it would
change because hitler attacked
stalin then that
was a strategic mistake he made
but left us with the cold war afterwards
and so in this darkest it's the lowest
point right now
he recites this poem on the radio
this is by arthur hugh clough say not
the struggle not available
the labor and the wounds are vain the
enemy faints not nor faileth
and as things have been they remain
if hopes were dupes fears may be liars
it may be in the smoke concealed your
comrades chase
even now the flyers and but for you
possess the field
i'll interrupt to say when you're in a
fight
the pattern is always the same at the
beginning there's a
number of the enemy and then there's a
larger number and then there's a larger
number
that's always how it starts right and of
course of course the mind
full fear of course imagines that the
number is infinite
what this poem is about is we don't know
the number
we can only hope and we must hope he
goes on
for while the tired waves vainly
breaking
seem here no painful inch to gain
far back through creaks and inlets
making comes
silent flooding in the mane
and not by eastern windows only when
daylight comes comes in the light
in front the sun climbs slow how slowly
but westward look the land is bright
that was an appeal to us in the west
right
after he finished that he called violet
bottom carter he didn't talk to her all
that much at that time
and you know he was a very great man and
she was an old woman
and he got her on the phone and violet
and she was balling
and he said did you hear our poem
how close was this that's our poem too
you